do you ever feel if you ever wish there
was more like i guess western humor
in comedy yeah because a lot of it does
kind of feel a lot of it's very anime
it's very like some of it's very
slapstick
what would classify though as like
western comedy
right that's the question because big
slapstick as well as
technically i i i don't i don't
necessarily even think the japanese
humor is as
slapstick as we like to point out i
think it is i think there's a youtuber
video on this
and it's like well there's like i mean
there's a lot of there's tv shows in
japan right where like the whole comedy
is like game shows with their like
language right with the
oh yeah like there's a bunch of other
stuff like that but i feel like
at least in western we're like really
[ __ ] brutal with our comedy
you know what i mean like yeah yeah like
you watch something like always sunny
and it's like
i couldn't imagine anything like that
coming out like a family guy in japan
right right it's weird though because
you have
the game shows here which go above and
beyond what we would think is acceptable
yeah but then when for some reason
comedy it's like they don't really joke
about that kind of stuff right
yeah right like it's a lot of wordplay
in japan i feel like japanese
a lot of wordplay a lot of wordplay
right but like they have like the show
like [ __ ]
orgasm wars yeah japan yeah where it's
basically a show about
if a dude can make another dude come
yeah that's the whole premise
yeah yeah yeah aggie recently did a
video on it but basically the most
famous one was
there was this it was it was versus this
like
super professional japanese like male
porn star who can like
he says like i can control when i come
basically
so he's like so he's like it's a 40
minute shoot
all right i'll comment i could come at
command yeah yeah basically he was like
i can comment command which means
that if you tell me not to come i'll
never come yeah and then
he had to verse this guy this um
yeah it was a versus like he basically
had to verse this guy uh he was a
bartender in shinjuku nichole which is
like the gay district of shinjuku yeah
and he's like considered to be he he
says
he can make any man come with his skills
right right so basically they put him
they put both of them in a room
right this is on tv by the way on
national tv so they put him in a room
he's inside the male porn star is like
inside of a box that's completely
covered and the gay guy
gets in basically and you don't see
anything but
they're both mic'd up so you can hear
everything
and basically how does this pass
television
and of course you know with traditional
japanese television like in the corner
there's like always a reaction
and this is a bunch of people just
[ __ ] losing themselves
just watching it suck off a game like
doesn't like make him not like
immediately he makes him not in like
five minutes and the funniest part is
like
obviously like you know watching the
male porn star like come on national tv
but then there's gay guys coming out and
being like
gorge
that's so [ __ ] it's so cool you hear
like the dick sucking sounds
oh yeah it's on youtube as well mind you
oh
if you look it up i guarantee it's on
youtube it's crazy that like that's
like totally acceptable yeah but then
like their humor doesn't
maybe not even like it's not allowed but
they don't really find that funny right
maybe i don't know
they find it funny oh okay yeah yeah
like that that was one of the most like
legendary pieces are they that funny but
then why would you reckon that something
like sunny
would be do you reckon that would be
funny to japanese people really have you
watched sunny yeah i've seen a bit of it
yeah
they probably think man these these
people are really rude yeah
yeah yeah i don't know because like the
the reason i've really enjoyed konasuba
over something like say sakamoto
is that a connoisseur was like way more
character-based comedy
i very much like enjoy character-based
comedy where
well it's just like mr bean yeah yeah
exactly
sorry to cut you off but and no that's
that's like the perfect analogy where a
lot of comedy anime
is the perfect bean yeah a lot of the
comedy anime i see is just like hey
there's this one joke and it's funny
like the first few times
let's let's see how far we can stretch
it but essentially eventually i'm gonna
get bored yeah whereas with a lot of
like you know sitcoms and everything
like that
you know it's it's a lot of it's a lot
of character-based comedy where you know
some of the best moments are
seeing how knowing the characters and
seeing how they will interact with each
other
and you know that's what the comedy
builds off of